that's what it feels like debating young
liberals first let me get a few things
out of the way I have a big nose puffy
hair and perfect teeth ready scanning a
puffy face I've seen how much you
liberals like to make personal attacks
so I figured I'd beat you to the punch
the Israel Hamas conflict continues I've
actually seen some comments on here
saying Israel was just chomping at the
bit for the truce to wear out it's
incredibly moronic I know there really
was no truce that wore out Hamas
actually started launching all rockets
into innocent civilian areas of Israel
for over a month before Israel finally
retaliated Israel finally said all right
you guys that's enough I warned you now
I'm gonna have to bend you over my knee
some have also said well I think we can
both agree that it's just such a
terrible conflict that the government
needs to intervene at this point who do
you think started this conflict NAMBLA
all right listen closely you punks
because you're about to be educated the
Palestinian government Hamas whose main
purpose is to destroy Israel and make no
mistake that's why they exist decided to
attack innocent civilians in Israel they
did not target military bases they
targeted innocent civilians to be honest
I don't think any negotiations are true
should be made at all until Hamas is
completely removed of power
Hamas is officially recognized by the
United States and European nations as a
terrorist organization the destruction
of Israel is practically their mission
statement to negotiate with these people
is honestly just ridiculous it's like
giving a gun to a [ __ ]
I know the whole oppression thing take a
lot of people off and people said well
Israel's really trying to expand its
borders and they're oppressing the other
nations but expanding its borders among
its enemies are you out of your tree sir
have you looked on a map Israel is
surrounded by nations who would like
nothing more than to blow them off the
face of the earth geographically and
population wise Israel should have no
capabilities of oppressing anyone
whatsoever if a couple of centuries ago
some warlords looked at a map of the
Middle East that would officially have
declared Israel a conquered nation
Israel is this some kind of joke they're
surrounded and outnumbered I give them
two weeks well what about
Palestinian children listen nobody likes
seeing innocent life lost on either side
and to the conservatives out there give
credit where credit's due these
Palestinian children are the most
resourceful people on the planet when it
comes to finding rocks where do I keep
getting these rocks they live in a
desert climate there shouldn't be that
many there I bet you could drop a
Palestinian child into the Alaskan
tundra come back two days later he would
be pelting me with his hoard of stones
speaking of Alaska I can't wait till we
reduce our dependence on foreign oil and
send these countries back to the dark
ages from whence they came within oil
money these people wouldn't even have
rocks to throw they'd be really
non-threatening just throwing whatever
they can at you hello Huck bog who is
that a pile of sand no no that was
unpleasant and God my teeth and
everything I'm gonna do my best to avoid
that in the future and as for Sarah
Palin she's fine I think she's been
great for Alaska I think she could have
been great for the country um I don't
think I want to see her run again and
it's really through no fault of her own
I just mean the media did such a number
on her I feel like Mitte watching
ringside stay down rock last but not
least proposition 8 to be honest I don't
even know why this is a talking point I
mean it was past it's over get over it
proposition 22 was passed a while ago
the Supreme Court said we don't really
know if we want the will of the people
to be done so we're gonna trump that
then finally the collective came
together and voted yes and Proposition 8
so regardless of my opinion most people
in America don't really think it's a
civil rights issue so I will say this
people comparing homosexuals wanting the
technical term marriage to the civil
rights movements of African Americans is
honestly silly you're talking about a
group of people who were sold from the
country unwillingly into slavery where
they were abused and mistreated for
centuries were where blood was shed
wars were fought and to compare that to
friction anyway thanks for watching next
week is going to be all new stuff I
really appreciate the support from you
guys out there be sure to subscribe and
god bless